today we're going to play a match with
the russian matroshka dolls after each
point you win
you place the doll on the table and if
you hit the doll you lose the points and
go one step back
first one to get to the smallest one
wins
okay let's make the draw i'll take this
side okay
you get the red [ __ ] but i'm i'm
confident with this
this little one there we go
how can you lose with that team bandana
dubba
oh
no i'm placing it on the backhand side
no she's lost the bandana there's no way
we're gonna win this point
it's okay still defending the back
outside
[Music]
we can do this
that's that's some impressive playing
guys otters is playing better when the
babushkas get smaller yeah that's true
next is this
why are you laughing i had it under
control
time to open up mama matruska
[Music]
[Laughter]
i get to progress we should have like
mini bandanas that i put on
yes
[Music]
okay you're back
no a bit smaller than the first one
oh you got two of my defense second
defense over here
newest member of the team
i think it was the wind okay let's check
what the vir says and
that's a clear hit one step back you
might be seeing a pattern here
there's five more in here yeah imagine
five
more and we're supposed to play with
them
whoa whoa
whoa
maybe taller but i'm i'm fuss
[Music]
how did that go on my newest recruit
this is the matarska
[Music]
and this is the ball
they're all looking at me
they're still quite scary looking like
where did it go maybe it's just
distracting me more if i put it there
but
let's go with that
[Music]
he's knocking down his own team i said
it's going to distract
me you were right it's like a half of a
ping pong ball
[Music]
oh yes nice one
there we have it
i i'm sorry that's for fun i'll leave
this here
at this point this makes this makes no
[Music]
sense
always have to go for our internet in
any situation you always have to go for
it
[Music]
you mean there's still one more yeah
there's one more
i wonder what's the right technique for
this
not a single shot was hit with the dot
well this is so small you can
you can go there
[Music]
so that there is the
final generation
well done and guys we heard there's
still a lot of you
who haven't subscribed don't don't do
that remember to subscribe
oh i lost my life so help pongfinity and
subscribe to our channel
until next time